today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video we have
news from a corona virus vaccine trial
that I am going to call the best
possible news at this stage of the
vaccine development process there's been
a lot of articles in the last 12 16 18
hours saying this is miraculous news or
this is tremendous news or fantastic
less than sort of it adding an adjective
to it in that way what we can say is
knowing the development process of a
vaccine which we'll talk about
momentarily this is essentially as good
as it gets at this stage in the process
we have a phase 1 trial which achieved
100% immunity 100% meaning protective
antibodies were the result in every
person who received the doses with
limited limited side-effects this is
early in the process but at this stage
this is the best possible result let's
look at the details the manufacturer of
this vaccine is moderna they've already
safety tested the vaccine this was a
phase 1 trial for efficacy does it work
at protecting someone and indeed the
first 25 people got either 25 or 100
milligram doses all of them had antibody
levels at or greater than the antibody
levels of people who get coronavirus and
recover from it naturally they did a
second round where eight more people
receive doses the vaccine again elicited
neutralizing antibodies in all eight of
those participants at or above the
levels of the antibodies that someone
who again has had the virus recovers
naturally you have a certain level of
antibodies the vaccine elicited that
level of antibodies or greater and then
those eight people's antibodies then
were able to defeat the virus in a test
tube so this is very very big news now
in terms of side-effects of that second
group of eight participants one person
had what's called grade 3
adverse events in terms of side-effects
that grade three is pretty serious your
daily activity is markedly reduced with
grade three they're considered severe
side effects you usually need some
assistance as a result of the side
effects you usually need some kind of
medical intervention and sometimes
hospitalization that was with the higher
dose they've determined they don't need
the higher dose to generate enough
antibodies so that is an important thing
as well what else can we say about this
you still have to sort out that there's
a lot that still needs to be sorted out
but this is very very important in terms
of getting on the way to a vaccine on
the fastest possible schedule now
there's a lot of different important
things that we have to discuss there's a
general scientific advancement that this
vaccine represents because this is
finally a it's potentially successful
for now until it's widely approved for
mass use we'll call it it's a
potentially successful mRNA vaccine now
this is a whole new type of vaccine most
vaccines that we have right now for
other diseases use either inactivated or
weakened doses of the disease you're
trying to protect against to generate
the antibody response this type of
vaccine from moderna for coronavirus
it's an mRNA vaccine it works on a
completely different method by tricking
the body into producing specific viral
proteins rather than introducing
weakened versions of the virus into the
human body there can be much more
powerful immunity generated by this type
of vaccine and it can also be much more
straightforward to produce which is a
really important part of this and so we
should talk about production of the
vaccine a little bit one of the key
things in vaccine production when it's
urgent
right now we have an urgent situation
getting this vaccine one month earlier
could save a lot of people and it can
keep a lot of people out of the hospital
so one of the things that comes up when
you have an urgent vaccine development
is if you wait until you have all phases
testing finished before you start
producing it you're way behind because
it takes a long time to produce huge
numbers of doses we are talking here
about billions of total doses that would
need to be produced for the planet of
course you'll likely have more than one
company the mederma vaccine moderna
vaccine is unlikely to be the vaccine
for the whole planet but you still need
to produce hundreds of millions of doses
so what is happening in partnership with
the company Lanza moderna is already
moving forward on establishing
manufacturing capacity for this vaccine
and they're going to start making it in
July now this is very important because
the phase 3 trial of the drug of the
vaccine doesn't start until July what
we're about five weeks from that as of
right now they are looking to start
making this vaccine while it is still
being tested and this is the fastest way
to eventually get it to people if it
works now it's a risk right you start
producing hundreds of millions of doses
maybe Phase three doesn't go well and
you've wasted a bunch of money that's
why in our system the way we do medicine
financially this represents a risk but
they're doing it and this is a really
really important thing they are going to
start production in just weeks as the
vaccine is still being tested so that
hopefully if things go well in the fall
you would have some significant number
of doses available now here's one of the
difficulties that you get two phase
three trial starts in July it can take
about 40 43 45 days to generate the full
antibody response to prove that this
works
that's mid-august already then how do
you actually prove that it protects you
right you you generate the antibodies in
about 40 days but then you need to make
sure that it actually protects you from
the disease well normally the way you do
it in a phase 3 trial is you follow a
huge swath of people for four months six
months nine months a year and then after
that time you would be able to say hey
only 5% of these people got it or only
you know compared to some other portion
that's how you would figure out that it
works
but the problem is that when these phase
three test subjects have the antibodies
in mid-august
only a few percent of the country will
have been infected so you could
potentially need to observe these people
for a really really long time before you
can say hey they were infected at a far
lower rate than the general population
they didn't not catch it by chance they
didn't catch it because of the vaccine
so what do you do well there's something
called a challenge trial where you take
vaccinated people and you deliberately
expose them to the virus to see if they
get infected this is not typically done
with vaccines and right now there is no
- in Phase three trials and right now
there's no challenge trial planned I
don't know how else you accelerate Phase
three
normally phase three is long and it
means we just follow these people and
see if they get the virus so will there
be a challenge trial done so we can more
quickly figure out does the vaccine work
for large numbers of people hasn't been
discussed yet we don't know so based on
all of that the soonest that we might
have limited availability of this
vaccine if everything goes perfectly
would be sometime in the fall it would
probably be for health care workers
initially then later you would get to
the most vulnerable populations then
significantly later you would
potentially have the capacity for
everybody but this is excellent news
insofar as at this stage this is the
best you can hope for 100% immunity and
limited side-effects only with that
higher dose which it turns out we don't
actually need now what we need to
prepare for is the flood of vaccine
disinformation that's what I want to
talk about next so we're already seeing
it it's about to get much worse there is
going to be a corona virus vaccine
disinformation war that is going to make
the measles vaccine disinformation seem
like child child's play and we're
already seeing in Bill Gates conspiracy
theories conspiracy conspiracy theories
that the corona virus itself was a
man-made plan to create a pretext to
give everybody a vaccine so you can you
know the insert your conspiracy theory
sterilization population control
whatever I'm not going to give you every
example but we've seen it all and we now
have as I told you earlier very
encouraging developments on a number of
new vaccines and most recently from
moderna moderna announcing in an early
trial of their vaccine everybody who got
the vaccine generated antibodies at or
greater than the level that a natural
coronavirus recovery generates Phase
three set to start in July all good news
but meanwhile the corona virus vaccine
disinformation war he's already scaling
up before we get the vaccine we are
going to have virally spreading
propaganda about the vaccine there's the
stuff in that bogus documentary plan
Demick from a couple of weeks ago you've
got a lot of pseudoscience around
coronavirus already 5g conspiracy
theories tied to corona virus you've got
the president wondering about injecting
bleach and Lysol doctor foul he pulled
into all sorts of conspiracies and on
and on and on and there's a really good
piece in the new york times by kevin
ruse which suggests this is just the
beginning of the propaganda fight around
the corona virus vaccine he says there
will be a very loud movement that is
going to try to convince the public that
the eventual coronavirus vaccine or
vaccines are dangerous they are lethal
they are bad for you they are a menace
they are part of all sorts of horrible
conspiracies involving governments or
elites or Bill Gates or whoever and the
important thing to understand is that
they only need to convince some people
to potentially prevent heard immunity
and they only need to convince some
people to create absolute havoc just
look at what they've done with measles
and the outbreaks that have been caused
over the last few years we know that
this is going to happen particularly
because of the urgency of this vaccine
so we know we may have shortened
observation period surveillance periods
for people who have received the vaccine
and we would do that safely in the sense
that it would be done with vaccines
already proven to be safe the question
would be well normally you might want to
confirm that the vaccine gives you
immunity for a year after six months we
might say listen it gives six months of
immunity let's start giving it to people
that is going to be used by the
anti-vaxxers to argue it's not been
tested the the testing has been
short-circuited short-circuited is a
wild experiment so that's one layer that
we can expect number two we know that to
really produce the vaccine at scale and
get to billions of doses organizations
like the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation will almost certainly have to
be involved
they are already the targets of anti VAX
activists and they've been the targets
for a long time sometimes it's Bill
Gates wants to profit from the vaccine
sometimes it's Bill Gates wants to
control the population with a vaccine
and then number three is Kevin Roose
points out we might have a period after
the vaccine is available where Airlines
might say listen to fly with us you need
a certificate of vaccination this would
not be a govern government mandated
vaccine it would be a private company
like JetBlue might say our rule is for
safety we require a vaccine certificate
this will explode in the anti-vaxxer a
vaccination has been one of their
talking points for a long time now of
course vaccinations if you want to fly
JetBlue
is very different than the government is
forcing everybody to get a vaccine so
the point is this is going to be a fight
and it's going to go beyond the normal
recesses of the internet you know we're
used to natural medicine websites and
this sort of thing doing anti-back stuff
but my prediction is that the corona
virus anti vax propaganda is going to
have wider distribution than just those
enclaves on the internet so what we need
to do and what Kevin Roose says in his
New York Times article needs to happen
is that the pro-vaccine movement which
we call science and medicine needs to
mobilize now science about vaccines
needs to be disseminated and in our
system being proactive is rarely
rewarded being proactive is rarely done
so I'm skeptical that there will be any
such coherent effort but it's important
that it be done and we're going to
continue doing it hey Monday we've got a
huge Memorial Day membership special the
show is going to be off on Memorial Day
what with coronavirus since we're all
just stuck at home
we've not had an off day for something
like four months or somethin longer we
are taking Monday off we are going to do
a one-day Memorial Day membership
special it's gonna be an unconscionable
discount attorneys general are beating
down my door saying David don't do it
it's too big of a discount but we're
gonna do it anyway to be notified about
this great membership discount on Monday
Memorial Day just get on our mailing
list sign up for the mailing list at
david pakman.com we'll take a quick
break let me know what you think about
the vaccine trials and propaganda on
Twitter where you can find me at D
Pakman
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Wesley Devers and Linda adenoid
thanks to Wesley and Linda so appreciate
your support
today's longtime sustainer of the days
Alan Friedrich very very much appreciate
that who's been a member five years and
I can't believe it but today is the 10
year membership anniversary of Bob young
Bob Young who I know personally out from
our affiliate K&Y Oh in Fort Bragg
California Bob has been a member 10
years to the day unbelievable
achievement thank you Bob so much for
your support hope to check in with you
soon grab a membership yourself at join
pakman.com Donald Trump blurted out
yesterday during a brief QA after
another one of these coronavirus
propaganda events that he has been
taking hydroxychloroquine for weeks now
my immediate reaction I don't know that
he's telling the truth and by the end of
this story I imagine many of you will
share these doubts what doctor would
allow a president to take something
lacking any demonstrated benefit with a
high side effect risk prophylactically
particularly when Donald Trump is a
borderline or actually obese which has
negative interactions with
hydroxychloroquine it sounds weird but
here is Trump saying it the context was
attacking whistleblower Rick right
here's Trump claiming to be taking
hydroxi chloroquine as he always inserts
a sniff between the two words but you
people don't want to write the the news
you know but if you look but he's the
one that signed the application at the
very important forum he signed it now if
he doesn't believe in it why would he
sign it and a lot of good things have
come out about the hydroxy a lot of good
things have come out and you'd be
surprised at how many people are taken
and especially the frontline workers
before you catch it the frontline
workers many many are taking it I happen
to be taking it I happen to be taking it
contracted hydroxychloroquine
when right now yeah a couple of weeks
ago started taking it because I think
it's gonna have heard a lot of good
stories and if it's not good I'll tell
you right I'm not gonna get hurt by it
it's been around for 40 years for
malaria for lupus for other things I
take it frontline workers take it a lot
of doctors take excuse me a lot of
doctors take it I take it now I hope to
not be able to take it soon because you
know I hope they come up with some
answer do we believe white house doctors
would let from go on a medication
because he heard a lot of good stories
so either Trump is taking it and it's
crazy since it has large side effect
risks Trump is in his 70s with
cardiovascular health compromise or
Trump is lying about it and that's also
crazy either way this is crazy
it's either stupidity or dishonesty now
the back story is that
hydroxychloroquine among many others is
one possible treatment for corona virus
that we looked at months ago I have no
idea logical opposition to it I listed
it for you on a list of about seven or
eight drugs before Donald Trump ever
mentioned it I think it's fine to look
into it so far the good randomly
controlled trials randomized controlled
trials don't show that it works now
here's another interesting thing when
you look into how hydroxychloroquine is
dosed for malaria which is what it's
approved for it's one dose per week so
you typically would start a week before
going to a country that has malaria risk
you take one dose then you take one dose
a week while you're there and then you
continue it for four weeks after you
leave the wacky ideas from people like
Sean Hannity and others is you take
chloroquine daily so question one is
this Trump claimed to be taking one dose
per week when he says I've been on it
for two weeks has Trump been taking it
daily for two weeks which would really
be wacky
so then Trump says the White House
doctor signed off on him taking this oh
I I think for whatever it's worth I take
it I was I I would have told you that
three four days ago but we never had a
chance because you never asked me the
question the White House did the White
House doctor recommend that you take
that is that why your White House doctor
didn't wreck
no I asked him what do you think you
said well if you'd like it and said yeah
I'd like it I'd like to take it a lot of
people are taking a lot of frontline
workers are taking hydroxychloroquine a
lot of Front well I don't take it
because hey people said oh maybe he owns
the company no I don't know the company
you know what I want the people of this
nation
to feel good I don't want them being
sick and there's a very good chance that
this has an impact so there he says well
no the White House doctor didn't come to
me about it I asked him and he said it's
okay for you to take it now here's Jeff
Mason from Reuters asking what's the
evidence that it actually works
prophylactically and listen to what
Donald Trump says taking it for about a
week and a half now and I'm still here
I'm still can you explain so though you
what is the evidence that it has a
preventative here we go you ready here's
my evidence I get a lot of positive
calls about it
the only negative I've heard was the
study where they gave it was at the VA
with you know people that aren't big
Trump fans gave it and we've done the
greatest job maybe of anything in the VA
he gets calls about it so that's his
evidence I like how he says the only
evidence that it doesn't work is that
thing from the VA that's the best
randomized control trial that we have
that's the one that has a large sample
size and Trump says other than that
which is by the way the best test we
have the best trial we have there's
evidence that it does work
prophylactically now shortly after Trump
said this chaos completely ensued and
the White House dr. Sean Connolly put
out a memo about Trump and chloroquine
and a whole bunch of people said look
here's the letter here is the proof that
Trump is taking hydroxychloroquine look
at the letter it doesn't say Trump is
taking it it's written in the most vague
way possible and it doesn't say Trump is
on the drug the letter that was
published says two weeks ago a trump
staffer tested positive for the virus
the president is in good health Trump
and the doctor had discussions about
hydroxychloroquine and they concluded
the benefit outweighs the relative risk
I continue to monitor studies the letter
doesn't say we have put Donald Trump on
hydroxychloroquine
so I'm increasingly thinking this is
something Trump blurted out to get a
reaction and it's not even true although
we may never know FDA has a warning says
avoid the use of hydroxychloroquine
outside of a hospital or clinical trial
because of the potential increased risk
for serious heart related adverse events
and death so I don't actually care about
Trump having side effects at this point
listen if Trump is going to insist on
taking something and ignoring the
science he deserves whatever side
effects he gets as a result the problem
is that it puts others at risk it
encourages others to go and seek out
prescriptions for this medication it
puts Trump in extra danger if he's
telling the truth
sure and Trump by the way has
hypertension medication he takes that
increases the side effect risk of
hydroxychloroquine but for me the real
signal that Trump is lying is that the
letter doesn't actually say he's taking
it and Trump says I've been on it for a
week and a half or two if you're
properly taking it which is one dose per
week Trump saying I've been on it on a
week and a half or two
have you gotten one dose or two one dose
or two unless Trump is actually taking
this daily which is absolutely bonkers
or it may all be a lie we may never know
we may never know but let's talk about
some of the reactions to Trump's claim
so let me get to sort of a a tour of
reactions to Donald Trump's claim that
he's taking hydroxychloroquine
prophylactically again I don't know that
we believe it Trump shouldn't be taking
it but he also may be lying by talking
about it he's creating he has already
created a shortage for people who
actually need this medication for
approved uses like lupus and malaria
it's unproven as a corona virus
prophylactic and Trump doesn't have any
of the conditions that this drug is
actually approved to treat but he claims
to be taking it so last night Nancy
Pelosi Democratic Speaker of the House
says listen this drug has adverse
reactions under the sort of cardiac
umbrella and Trump's morbidly obese so
he shouldn't be taking it take a look at
this as far as the president is
concerned
the our peas are president and I would
rather he not be taking something that
has not been approved by the scientists
especially in his age group and in his
shall we say weight group had but it is
morbidly obese they say so I I think it
was it's not a good idea so this
immediately triggered a whole span of
reactions some people gleefully going
all the way up to bordering on fat
shaming Trump other people reacted
furious that Nancy Pelosi would be
making such baseless claims about
Trump's morbid obesity so let's go
through this item-by-item
hydroxychloroquine has a number of
adverse effects it includes cardiac
arrhythmias hypoglycemia and a number of
neuropsychiatric effects if you have a
cardiovascular deficiency which Donald
Trump does he is overweight we'll talk
about obesity in a moment this is a drug
you should probably avoid unless totally
necessary it's clearly not necessary for
Donald Trump to take this if he is
indeed taking it now it also causes a
bunch of neuropsychiatric symptoms it
includes agitation insomnia confusion
mania hallucinations paranoia depression
catatonia psychosis suicidal ideation
what's interesting about that is Trump
already exhibits a whole bunch of those
so we may not even be able to tell the
difference Trump is regularly agitated
he claims to sleep only a few hours a
night he's regularly confused his
Twitter use is completely manic he's
completely paranoid you get the idea so
now we get to the question is Pelosi
right that Trump is morbidly obese Trump
claims to be six foot three inches tall
and weighed 239 pounds that would put
you out of BMI of twenty nine point nine
the line for obesity is thirty now I
know BMI is very flawed but for most
people you know Trump is not a
bodybuilder for example where BMI
doesn't work it's a pretty good rule of
thumb
so the suspicion is Trump claims to be
6-3 to 39 because that puts him
literally 1 pound from being obese
we know Trump is not six foot three
inches tall you can look at Trump in
pictures with other people whose heights
we know for example Justin Trudeau the
Canadian Prime Minister is six foot two
Trump is clearly shorter than Trudeau in
pictures and we've got a bunch of
examples so if Trump is 6 1 and 239 he's
obese Trump is more likely 6 1 and 260
he is higher in obesity however he is
not morbidly obese usually we use some
combination of you're a hundred pounds
overweight you have a BMI above 40 or a
BMI above 35 with obesity related
conditions like diabetes or blood
pressure Trump even at 6 1 to 60 as a
BMI of 30 4.3 so listen guys Nancy
Pelosi was wrong Donald Trump is not
morbidly obese by any reasonable
definition he is certainly obese and he
should not be taking prophylactic
hydroxychloroquine so that gets us once
again back to the question of is Trump
really taking it what doctor would
prescribe for an older obese guy with a
heart problem something that is
ineffective in preventing coronavirus
and increases the rate of cardiac
arrhythmia final takeaway is we don't
know whether Trump is on this and we may
never know but fortunately at least one
Fox News host is sounding the alarm
about what Donald Trump claims to be
doing big moment on Fox News Fox host
Neil Cavuto has not been playing up
Donald Trump's promotion of
hydroxychloroquine he's not stopped
short of going after Trump for his
absolutely ridiculous musings about
bleach injections and now after Donald
Trump has asserted that he is taking
prophylactic hydroxychloroquine to
protect himself from coronavirus Neil
Cavuto is saying this will kill you if
you have certain comorbidities let's
listen to the start of Neil Cavuto
segment about this yesterday that was
stunning the president United States
just to acknowledge that he is taking a
drock's of chloroquine a drug that meant
really to treat malaria and lupus the
president has insisted that
enormous benefits for patients so either
trying to prevent will already have a
Koba 19 the fact of the matter is though
when the president said what have you
got to lose in the number of studies
those certainly vulnerable the
population have one thing to lose their
lives then Cavuto going in even harder a
little bit later on in the segment
saying this will kill you in certain
situations the VA study to which the
president alluded wasn't a loaded
political one it was a test on patients
there and those who took it in a
vulnerable population including those
with respiratory other conditions they
died I want to stress again they died if
you are in a risky population here and
you were taking this as a preventive
treatment to ward off the virus or in a
worst case scenario you are dealing with
the virus and you are in this vulnerable
population it will kill you I cannot
stress enough this will kill you so
listen Neil Cavuto is horrible Neil
Cavuto has been spreading disinformation
on Fox News for decades this is not any
kind of praise of Neil kabuto
journalistic skills or credentials in
any way but Cavuto is right about this
maybe he knows Fox News has a
disproportionately older audience Cavuto
is saying the right thing and he's now
in hot water with the virulent trumpets
who are calling for his firing now one
thing that Trump said didn't look so
good was that one VA study that says
hydroxychloroquine doesn't seem to work
the tree coronavirus it is a good thing
that Neil Cavuto pointed out that's a
good study in fact we have a lot of
different studies on hydroxychloroquine
that's probably the best randomly
controlled randomized controlled trial
with a placebo group and it was a
blinded study so good good that Neil
Cavuto is doing this meanwhile Sean
Hannity and Laura Ingraham and others on
Fox News have been gleefully promoting
this drug and it's completely dystopian
we have Fox News hosts arguing with each
other
which drugs people should be taking
rather than leaving it to the doctors
here's Laura Ingraham bringing on a
guest last night who says we should be
thrilled that Donald Trump is taking
this because he's brilliant check out
this wacky woman dr. Yvette Lozano dr.
Lozano people on television news anchors
guess or freaking out about this
what about this should we the American
people know is that irresponsible of him
to be taking hydroxychloroquine and why
do they care I think the people of the
United States need to know that they
have a brilliant President of the United
States and that he wants to keep himself
safe and healthy so that he can guide us
through this pandemic he's done an
incredible job he is saving thousands
and thousands of lives and I commend him
for coming out publicly and sharing with
his people that he is taking this drug
that it is completely safe and that
doctors need to start prescribing it
immediately of course it's not
completely safe and just a reminder I
have no idea logical opposition to
hydroxychloroquine working they are
promoting this as a miracle drug and
that is not based in fact last thing is
this entire hydroxychloroquine thing
from yesterday a distraction
from the number of coronavirus deaths
from Trump firing his fourth Inspector
General in a few weeks we are still
covering all of those stories but other
media outlets are spending a lot of time
on this instead of some of those stories
and it could be once again one of trumps
planted distractions we'll have more
cover of coverage of this on the david
packard show instagram page at david
patten show follow us there i'll be
right back
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Ross Douthat who's a columnist at
the New York Times and also author of
the recent book the decadent society how
we became the victims of our own success
great to have you on Ross thank you yeah
thanks for having me it's a pleasure so
a lot of what you write about applies to
the situation in which we find ourselves
today but in order to kind of get into
that conversation when you talk about a
decadent society what do you mean by
that because it may it may not be
obvious to some in our audience right so
I'm trying to use the word decadence not
to just mean you know chocolate-covered
strawberries and you know bondage dens
and orgies and so on but I'm trying to
use it as a kind of technical label for
a stage that really successful
civilizations tend to reach when they
become very rich and powerful and all of
their sort of systems governmental
economic are well established hard to
chain we're on it
any comment essentially victims of their
own success they're so powerful and rich
that they stop doing the kind of things
that you need to do to innovate both in
politics and science and culture they
stop having as many babies because you
know people have other things to do at
their time and so they enter into
periods and sort of torpor stagnation
and repetition which the book argues
we've been in at least up until you know
the current crisis that we entered into
while I was on my book tour how does
this relate to some of the systems that
up until three months ago many of us
maybe assumed were pretty strong and
whose fragility
has actually been exposed by the
coronavirus does that in any way play
into this stagnation sort of that that
you apply to economies that in countries
that are in this deck in it phase where
we very quickly realized hey that
great-looking stock market was actually
not quite so strong the supply chain for
many consumer products and even some
food items was not nearly as strong as
we believed employment was not as strong
as we believed how does that play into
this idea it plays in I mean in a lot of
different ways but I'll give you a
couple examples one is you know the
point that you made about supply chains
one of the things that the Western world
has been doing basically over the last
40 years is overall growth has been
slowing down growth hasn't been nearly
as impressive as it was you know in the
heyday of the Industrial Revolution or
the post-war boom and so we've been
trying to essentially do two things one
spend way more money way more public
money basically and take on way more
debt in order to sort of create the
sense that we're still growing quickly
and to we're trying to wring out sort of
maximal efficiencies everywhere we can
find them in order to again sort of
Goose growth and with supply chains and
you know things like our basic supplies
of medical equipment and masks and so on
you can see the danger in in the second
trend where you're you know you're so
focused on efficiency because you know
that you know you won't get strong
growth without maximal efficiency that
you aren't actually prepared to be
flexible when a real crisis comes along
and turns out that efficiency isn't the
only good it's also good to have
stockpiles of medical equipment so
that's one one sort of pattern and
another pattern is just the way sort of
large bureaucracies by their nature are
built to pursue safety rather than
innovation and that's not a bad thing
per se
obviously you want the FDA and the CDC
to be focused on making sure that
medicine is safe and vaccines are safe
and so on but it makes them inflexible
not particularly adaptable and you end
up in this case with a sort of temporary
catastrophe like the kind we had with
testing in this country over over the
critical two months when we missed the
opportunity to contain the virus where
the bureaucracies default mode
is sort of the status quo is fine and we
just need to make sure everything's safe
and when you actually have a new
challenge you can't adapt to it
particularly quickly now when we think
about so the first element you mentioned
with the medical supplies it doesn't
seem to me as though the countries that
are not yet at a level of what what you
described as decadence uniformly did
better on that issue I mean there was
certainly a mix there were countries
that were more proactive South
korea-china not not trying to Taiwan I
believe that within Europe Greece
certainly was one that moved earlier and
sort of more aggressively but what other
factors should we be looking at because
it's not it can't simply be that it was
decadence that sort of prevented us from
being properly ready for that no it's
also just immediate experience right I
mean you you have a clear division
between how quickly and seriously East
Asian societies and East Asian politics
took this challenge and have seriously
the US and Western Europe took it mostly
because it's not just the East Asian
countries were in closer proximity to
China they also have sort of direct
experience of SARS you know in the
immediate past so they had sort of some
knowledge and a sense of how bad things
could get and sort of you know a sense
of the need to act quickly in a crisis
whereas in the US and Western Europe
there was a sense that well you know
something can happen in China and it
must be you know well it's just a
Chinese problem it's the kind of thing
that you know could only happen in you
know what I think a lot of people in the
West still think of China as a
developing country a country that's sort
of fundamentally different from the
developed world which it is in certain
ways but obviously not in others so
there's just I think yeah a level of
sort of recent experience and realism
about the real state of the world that
was stronger in East Asia than in the US
and Western Europe but I also think you
could say in at a larger level that
there are ways in which generally the
economies of East Asia do look a little
less decadent generally then when
certainly than Western Europe but also
in the u.s. in terms of sort of
their general willingness to sort of
embrace innovation they're sort of a
state capacity this term of art that
people use to refer to you know how good
a government is and getting things done
state capacity seems like it's been in
decline in the US over the last few
decades and maybe less so in East Asia
so there's a lot of different dynamics
going on so as we see in the in the
United States even though at the country
level we could say we are certainly one
of the richest countries in the world we
have achieved a degree of what you
describe as decadence the reality about
inequality means that for a large number
of people only maybe a sliver of some of
these benefits are actually reaching
them when you look at you know wage
growth over the last 40 years and how it
disproportionately has been for a small
upper echelon of the economy so to speak
or workers as the case may be what is
the relationship between a country that
top level has achieved this status that
you identify to the degree to which it's
uniformly or not uniformly distributed
amongst the people I think it depends I
think I think there are a couple of
different ways that you can get
inequality and one is more decadent and
one is less decadent right so if you
look at a period like late 19th century
America you have soaring inequality you
have the year of the robber barons the
great fortunes of the Rockefellers and
Carnegie's were being made and that
created all kinds of social problems
that eventually sort of led to the labor
movements of populist and progressive
you're and the New Deal but it wasn't an
inequality that really reflected
decadence it was an inequality that
reflected this age of innovation where
you had sudden innovations a few people
were capturing the returns and it took a
while for those returns to spread
throughout the population our own era
the last 30 years or so it looks like
that a little bit with Silicon Valley
where you have you know internet
innovation does occur Berg's and and so
on get rich and it doesn't spread out to
the rest of society but a lot of what
we've seen outside the internet economy
is a steady
general stagnation slowing rates of
growth where rich people aren't getting
rich by embracing innovative new
technologies they're getting rich just
through the power of investments and
compound interest and so on and this is
Thomas Piketty this is sort of the
argument it says this is not this is the
more libertarian in a way version of the
argument that he made in his book
capital in the 21st century where he
basically said you know as societies
sort of as growth slows down and
societies get older and people have
fewer kids great fortunes become more
and more consolidated and rich people
live off ramps and that kind of
inequality is more decadent and more
stagnant and less likely to ultimately
benefit society as a whole then the
inequality you get when you know people
are building the Transcontinental
Railroad and a lot of opportunists are
getting rich off that innovation one of
the things you talk about in the book is
the degree to which a lot of the same
political arguments just continue to be
had over and over again with no real
progress once a country reaches this
level of decadence and I think we can
intuitively see that if you follow
politics a lot of issues that are merely
political footballs you know debt and
deficit just kind of tossing it back and
forth what should the role of the United
States military be around the world do
low taxes on the rich trickle down or do
we need demand sights that you know a
lot of these it's the same arguments
over and over and over again can you
talk about why the repetitive nature of
these arguments is reinforced by the
decadence you write about I mean I think
decadence creates a world in which I
mean among other things there because
there isn't tremendous change going on
there aren't sort of it becomes hard to
win an argument to sort of decisively
win one way or another systems are
really hard to reform and change so you
know you'll get Barack Obama will be
elected president and everyone will say
oh this is you know the new New Deal is
the new Franklin Roosevelt they're going
to have a new age of liberal governance
and he passes Obamacare which is sort of
a jerry-rigged apparatus tacked on to an
existing welfare state passing it is
incredibly difficult and politically
costly and you get a huge backlash and
effectively
his presidency as a legislative force is
over two years in and then immediately
the Tea Party sweeps in and everyone
says ah well it's a new libertarian era
and you know Paul Ryan is the new you
know he's the new great reformer and
he's gonna you know undo the Great
Society or something but that doesn't
actually go anywhere because people
don't particularly want to undo the
Great Society and so you have you know
the libertarian moment quickly turns
into stalemate too so it's a combination
of societies can older they're more
resistant to change big programs
long-standing systems are more
impervious to change and so people argue
at the margins they argue about a 39%
top tax rate versus a 33% top tax rate
even while their rhetoric makes it sound
like you know it's the great clash
between capitalism and socialism and
citizens so that's been the pattern
certainly I think of the last of the
last 25 years or so the question is
whether it still holds or whether
populism on the right and Bernie Sanders
style socialism on the left are actually
going to sort of shift the underlying
dynamics but I don't think they've
actually shifted policy debates yet even
if they've shifted arguments somewhat so
you talk about candidates as a possible
way to shift this what about your
writing that there could be a crisis
moment that actually shakes things up is
the global pandemic we're dealing with
now potentially on the level of what
you're talking about or is it not even
big enough I mean it might not be big
enough well which is one of the things
one of the points I make in the book is
that decadence has all kinds of problems
but sometimes the kind of crisis you
need to really shift a society how do
decadence is so big that it's better to
stick with that consent that embrace the
catastrophe but look what the
coronavirus offers is an opportunity you
know it's it's a whole you know it's a
horrible human tragedy that in its
aftermath there will be an opportunity
to look at all the ways our systems have
failed to look at all the ways our
politics that's become stalemated and
didn't handle the crisis correctly and
say you know maybe we can do something
new and that could lead to you know
you could have an era when people say
okay well we really are going to you
know change how regulations work in the
healthcare sector to try and get more
medical innovation you've dipped in a
world where people say look we spent all
this money in a crisis why can't we
spend more money on public goods when
there isn't a pandemic around and so you
get a shift to the left in public policy
you can imagine a lot of shifts coming
out of this but I do think it's possible
that you know we will have this this
year of turmoil and then we will get a
vaccine and there'll be sort of this
sense of relief that things are back to
normal and people will have sort of gone
deeper into decadence in certain ways
like you know small businesses new
entrepreneurship will have been sort of
smushed down big companies will
benefited the most from the bailout
packages and from the feds policies
until you'll get more consolidation more
big companies that aren't particularly
innovative and so on you know more
people living their lives online and
instead of instead of getting married
and starting families you can imagine a
lot of ways in which this deepens
decadence potentially even as it offers
a chance to pull out of it a couple
weeks ago I interviewed Brian Greene and
one of the things we talked about
because it kind of mixes in well with a
few different things he deals with was
this idea that that I have which
increasingly I think is naive that if
there was some really life-altering
moment like for example intelligent
alien life arrives right something
really transcendent that it would
finally get humans to do away with these
differences that that as you talk about
often or the difference between a thirty
six and a thirty nine point six percent
top tax rate or whatever we would
finally get past all this stuff but I
have to say that the the fiasco that has
been the reaction to coronavirus where
you have people who you know all sorts
of conspiracies and you you all we don't
even have to go into it you know it that
has made me think that even something
like intelligent alien life maybe for a
month would would get us to rethink some
of our differences and then it would all
just kind of go back to normal to the
way things have been I don't know
well I mean the amusing thing is that we
have literally had
sort of footage of not probably not
actual aliens but at the very least UFOs
dropped in the middle of the coronavirus
crisis right you've had the Navy
releasing footage of unidentified flying
objects and you know except for a few
people who I follow on Twitter almost
nobody has cared to be clear that those
are not being presented as evidence of
aliens right but but regardless you
would think that that entire community
would have paid more attention they're
right they're being presented but they
are they're very mysterious objects that
are they'd go beyond I think the sort of
normal range of sort of grainy footage
of UFOs they are probably not aliens but
they certainly are really interesting
and in a different moment you would
imagine that sort of capturing the
imagination of the Internet but really
the Internet is more interested in you
know figuring out ways to blame
everything about the coronavirus on on
people that they dislike we've been
speaking with Ross Douthat
a columnist at the New York Times and
also author recently of the decadent
Society how we became the victims of our
own success Russ I so appreciate your
time thanks so much for having me it was
a pleasure the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
we have the makings of a new ultra
scandal for Donald Trump it is one where
I can sum it up really concisely and
that is corruption at the highest level
Donald Trump has now fired four
inspectors general in the last few weeks
the entire I'm taking hydroxychloroquine
gambit may even be a sort of semi
deliberate attempt to take attention
away actually from some of the things
Trump is doing and we've talked before
about the question what point is there
and having inspectors general if Trump
can just fire them when they're looking
into something he doesn't want them
looking into in case in point it appears
that Donald Trump's firing of Inspector
General Steve linic was specifically
because linic was investigating a u.s.
sale of weapons to Saudi Arabia that was
fast-tracked by Trump Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo under the auspices of Trump
declaring the situation with Iran an
emergency back in 2019
now this is the type of story that
doesn't get a lot of coverage it doesn't
get a lot of views I would be shocked if
this story does well on our YouTube
channel or on Facebook but it is alleged
scandal at the highest level because the
official statement was linic was fired
because he wasn't performing his job
well that's what Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said there are now numerous
lawmakers even some Republicans saying
this doesn't make sense this doesn't
pass the sniff test this was all to
cover up a dirty arms deal with Saudi
Arabia to get around congressional
approval of that deal so the allegation
goes that back in 2019 Trump made an
emergency declaration specifically to
clear the path for eight billion dollars
in military arms sales to Saudi Arabia
and United Arab Emirates the emergency
declaration was with regard to Iran the
the goal was as the story is being
alleged that by declaring an emergency
the arms deal doesn't need congressional
review in fact both the House and Senate
passed resolutions blocking the sale but
Trump vetoed the resolutions and kept
the sale going with this emergency
declaration we even have Republicans
concerned like Senator
grassley that the explanation for why i
jellinek was fired isn't making any
sense so admittedly we're just at the
start of this we only have a sort of
cloudy picture of what went on it could
be much worse than what I'm telling you
it could be different there could be
more to it but it is also in the mix
that Mike Pompeo was refusing to
cooperate with this investigation by IG
linic and we've since found out that as
part of his investigation the IG started
looking at claims that Mike Pompeo was
doing things like for example having
State Department employees walk his dog
pick up his dry cleaning and make dinner
reservations completely outside the
scope of course that would be something
that he should hire some kind of
personal staff for not use State
Department staff so this could be as
simple as Pompeo wanted to get linic out
of the way because linic was looking
into pompeii hose dog walking misuse of
staff time it could be way worse in that
it was part of a bigger conspiracy to
get around congressional approval to do
an arms deal but there are a whole bunch
of big corruption stories here and first
the facts of what went on with this
specific arms deal and emergency
declaration and the IG firing and the
investigation that needs to be figured
out that's this story number two is the
ongoing hypocrisy of Republicans with
regard to IDs in general under Obama
many of the same Republicans that now
stand aside as Trump fires IG after IG a
lot of those same Republicans when it
was Barack Obama were saying we need to
empower a inspectors general and we need
to make sure that a president can't get
rid of them they are silent now they are
silent now and these IG firings so far
we don't this one we're still figuring
out have been clear political
retaliations and then lastly there's
just the sniff test as I like to call it
you don't fire for inspectors general in
a few weeks under normal circumstances
Trump is taking apart every oversight
mechanism that we have and he's getting
away with it
Trump will say listen these
were never Trump errs they were tools of
the left and he'll get away with it
enough people hmm
hate Democrats on principle so much that
they will let him get away away with it
call it brainwashing call it hyper
partisanship whatever you call it
he's getting away with it unless we vote
him out in just a few months I can't
tell you right now what things are going
to be like in November I can only tell
you what things are like right now and
right now Donald Trump and Joe Biden are
seeing a shift in who is supporting them
and older voters are abandoning Donald
Trump and they are flocking to Joe Biden
in large numbers why do we care well we
care about every vote but in particular
we care because older voters are a key
voting group for Donald Trump if you
look back at the 2016 exit polls Trump
won voters age 50 or older by the
largest margin Trump one vote voters in
their 40s by a little bit and Trump lost
all age groups from 39 and under
Republicans in general have done better
with older voters than younger voters
for a very long time so the the
important thing is Trump needs older
voters to win in November back in 2016
Trump won voters aged 45 to 64 by 4%
right now we've seen a five-point swing
with Biden leading that group 45 to 64
by about one and a half points that's a
five and a half point reversal from 2016
normal caveats it's early a lot can
change when we look at voters 65 plus
Trump won that group by 13 points in
2016 he is now losing 65 plus by 1.2
Biden that is a 14-point swing now why
is this happening speculation it's
speculation right now someone wrote to
me and said David older folks are dying
from coronavirus and it's the Trump
older folks that are more likely to die
because they're not wearing masks or
staying home I understand the logic of
that it's been floated we don't have any
evidence
for that right now coronavirus in
general is the most sort of obvious
explanation older folks are most at risk
from coronavirus and they might react
the most strongly to Donald Trump's
mishandling of it this problem with
older voters that Trump is having could
explain why Trump is not doing well in
states with older populations Florida is
one such state that's a key state
Florida's population is the fifth oldest
in the country the latest polls have
Trump losing to Biden by six in Florida
more importantly for today's story
Quinnipiac has Trump losing by ten in
Florida among voters 65 and older so I
don't want to get anybody's hopes up
we've got to count every vote this is a
snapshot right now but if Trump loses
older voters in Florida by anything
close to ten even by six or seven it's
over for Trump
now if coronavirus starts to wane if the
economy recovers or appears to recover
and Trump can attach his name to the
recovery things could turn around very
quickly so you know when you start
slicing and dicing the electorate in
this way it's really difficult to glean
anything super useful from it what I do
think is interesting is the following we
believe that about 13% of people who
voted for Obama Biden in 26 in 2012
voted for Trump in 2016
13% of Obama's 12 voters went for Trump
in 16 if Biden can get back just half of
those people and not lose anybody that
voted for Hillary that translates to a 7
million vote victory in the popular vote
for Biden in 2020
now you could win the popular vote by 7
million and lose the electoral college
it's theoretically possible it we've
never seen it we've never seen it so now
go back and think people who were on
board with Obama in 2012 and voted Trump
for some reason in 2016 are they likely
to stick with Trump over a guy they
already voted for years prior and Joe
and Joe Biden if he only gets half of
them back it looks very good for Biden
again nothing is
guaranteed if Biden can win back just
half of those voters who went from Obama
in 12 to Trump in 16 he has a very very
good starting point for 2020 so what
does this mean for us nothing all it
means is every single one of us needs to
vote remember that on Monday Memorial
Day will have a huge David Pakman show
membership special get notified on
Monday Memorial Day by signing up for
our newsletter at david pakman.com it's
quick it's easy it's free and then
Monday you will hear about this King
credible membership discount no time for
the voice mail I'll talk to you on the
bonus show today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video